I think Breezy didn't stand up to his
mother for you I think he was a coward
well uh on this case like uh she need to
go back because uh yeah she needed to go
back but Debbie isn't that kind of
offensive if you need to go back it's
like no Jin and Rishi shock everyone by
announcing they're back together after
they broke up because his mom says she
does not support them getting married
does your family know that you guys are
engaged yes or no and that's all now at
this moment
yes a lot of detector determined that
was a lot
I was a cheater now I don't know if
rishi's a cheater but he sure does have
a hard time telling the truth he's just
lying about everything this becomes
evidence of the cast and they call him
out Jen is a treasure this is a treasure
and you're not treating that treasure
you know it's like come on Debbie sounds
like she's creating some space for her
son Julian to swoop in didn't you think
Jen was kind of cute and nice do you
think she kind of was like batting her
eyes at you a little bit
let's get into it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melicia part
two of the cello was a little dry in my
opinion next week on part three it looks
like things are going to heat up but
there are a few must-see moments that I
wanted to chat with you about from this
episode first up gave in my mood
apologized after an intense back and
forth LED my mood to storm off stage it
all started after Gabe questioned
Mahmoud about forcing Nicole to dress a
certain way he also asked if my mood
plans to quote Forest his and Nicole's
children to be Muslim mahmoud's initial
reaction to that
don't question what goes on in my house
that is not your place I'm so sorry that
this would put you in such a terrible
mood I really am
my moves in a mood
nothing new
I need you to be here with me my love be
strong I'm strong
I don't want to do that anymore well
leave the tree out of it my mood
I think the apology that ultimately
takes place comes in large part thanks
to Nicole's tears she was extremely
upset I want to see this one
but first Mahmoud makes his way back to
the camera who's the ass probably me
because I asked him a question yeah
shut up your mouse
why are you crying now why are you
crying now poor Nicole oh my gosh she
needs a hug man
I feel so bad
side note Debbie needs to go ahead and
start a fan line she always has them and
they're cute plus it's about to get hot
well at least in the States you just
want people to be nice to each other
alright fast forward Nicole breaking
down in tears gets to my mood and gave
and once Nicole and Mahmoud make their
way back to their seats Gabe speaks up
I want to apologize I'm sorry
explains that his dad and stepmom are
Muslims and they gave their children a
choice so it hits home closer than we
think they want to say sorry to
everybody
it's okay Mamu looks like that was hard
for him to do
but I'm glad he did it after he
apologizes Debbie gets up and gives
Nicole that hug she said she needed
which was sweet by the way I plan on
talking to Nicole soon so if you have
any questions drop them in the comments
I might not be able to get to all of
them but I'll definitely get you a few
and speaking of Debbie giving out some
tender loving care this episode she
reveals
she hasn't been in an intimate
relationship with someone in a long time
oh gosh it's probably
12 years or more maybe 14 years
because it is a special gift you give to
someone that is valuable and treasured I
love that it's beautiful dinner Nicole
are like yeah I can appreciate that
thought but dot dot I'm joking you know
Debbie is so vibrant now just think
about when she does get intimate with
the right one not the wrong one because
the wrong one can drain you but the
right one
her light is going to be blinding I can
see her floating down the street with a
big smile on her face now alright
finally let's talk about Rishi getting
caught up in a lie he really tried it I
was actually invited to a wedding a
mutual friend's wedding and Rishi was
also there at the beginning of the
episode he and Jen announced they are
seeing each other again after Jen broke
off their engagement when his mom said
she does not support them getting
married because of their 16-year age
difference jyn goes on to reveal that
once they got back in touch they got
reconnected on multiple levels I'm not
saying that we weren't intimate oh
okay yeah yeah
you know the first time in more than two
years right
first time in a long time
she said the first time in a long time
you know during the season Jin was
saying she hasn't slept with Rishi in
two years because quote he's not going
to buy the cow if he gets the milk for
free but I had a feeling she was giving
up something first time in a long time
and if she really wasn't more power to
her that's just hard to believe the way
Rishi has her hook
[Music]
please first time in a long time yes how
is that
it was pretty amazing
both of your faces
and how was it for you Rishi
salutation
that's impressive look Rishi has to chin
up like yeah the conversation goes from
their reawakened sex life to Rishi not
standing up to his family for Jen and
between Gabe and Miss Debbie I don't
know what pep talk the producers gave
them but they were coming in hot it
might have been the same pep talk they
gave debris you happy you don't have a
happy family
but I will say Debbie and Gabe
had tacked I can't make him choose
between his family and me just the way
the same way that if he were ever to ask
me to choose between my family and him I
mean
I I couldn't I think greasy didn't stand
up to his mother for you yep I think he
was a coward I think the way you let Jen
go and it's like I have to listen to my
mother there was no passion where was
your passion for you don't defend your
woman bro
well uh on this case like uh she need to
go back because uh yeah she need to go
back it's like now
this daddy is at that stage in life
where she is saying how she feels with
no filter bro you say a lot of words and
you like just dance in circles for no
for nothing like just say what you have
to say as the conversation moves along
Sean asked Jen if she's still engaged to
Rishi we're not engaged
a lot of things would have to happen and
I'm I'm not confident they would happen
yet Rishi has a completely different
answer Rishi do you consider Jen your
fiance or just your girlfriend
I think fiance is still
uh-uh
people might think that's cute oh
oh his wife but I see it as a lack of
respect you can't just claim me as your
fiance and you haven't done the work
also in my opinion whether he's aware of
it or not it just shows how much power
he thinks he has over Jane does your
family know that you guys are engaged
yes or no and that's all now at this
moment
yes straight up lied because when his
mom and Uncle come on camera they have
no clue Rishi says that he and Jen are
engaged again that Jen is his fiancee
how do you feel about that
I think they're not even aware about it
we heard with our ears we asked him does
your family know that you're engaged and
you're with Jen he says yes they know
so apparently they don't know
did you not know your parents were
coming on the show Rishi don't y'all
live together
it's bad enough to lie about something
like that but it makes it even worse
when you weren't even trying to be smart
about it it was a careless lie tell me
your first reaction when you found out
that Jen and Rishi were back in a
relationship together
news to me Jin's two besties also joined
the show and they had no clue jyn was
back with Rishi dang that's when you
know you were in a relationship you
probably have no business being in
because you're embarrassed to tell the
people who are closest to you the cast
starts to discuss what's holding Rishi
back from actually moving out of his
mom's house and building a life with Jen
in India as his wife and although I
understand Rishi has some cultural
things that are making the decision
tough for him Debbie makes a really good
point I think he wants the Best of Both
Worlds and doesn't want to commit he has
his his mom baby it's like you want to
be in my mom's house or don't want to
grow up exactly do you feel like Rishi
has not grown up no
and I'm like I'm telling you this bro
you don't got no balls you got to stick
up for your woman and then comes Nicole
who balances the conversation out I
think what we're forgetting here is just
like how insanely difficult it is to
break with tradition even if we want to
it's like so hard and we saw that with
submit and Jenny they went through the
fire with cement's parents for years and
rishi's Mom's main concern just like
submits moms is Jin's age now this is
still no excuse for rishi's player
Behavior specifically lying and
entertaining other women on social media
that's just what we know of rishi's got
no game y'all I I just have to put yeah
you got a lot of games
call it like you see again Jen is a
treasure this is a treasure and you're
not treating that treasure you know it's
like come on
daddy looks like she don't find a
treasure chest somewhere with all this
fabulous jewelry
somebody in the comments said she looks
like a pimp
I was cracking up all right back to
Rishi Sean asked rishi's Mom to talk
directly to Jen and she tells her if she
was a year or six months older than
Rishi she would accept her but because
that's not the case they can only be
friends thank you for that permission
I'm not gonna be age shamed I'm sorry
what kind of small heart do you have
lady did you teach your son to be that
way Rishi is like wait don't talk about
my mama now the conversation gets to a
point where the cast somewhat pressures
Rishi to sell his mom and Uncle the
truth about his current relationship
with Jen and after talking in circles he
finally does
foreign
[Applause]
I don't know if I should be happy about
that or not
I'm 99.
[Music]
she said he cannot get married oh thanks
honestly that might turn into a genuine
thank you one day I think Jen is dodging
a bullet Jen how do you feel now that
Rishi has told his mom that he plans to
marry you without her permission
it sounds great but it's a lot of talk
not a lot of action you know what if it
happens otherwise I mean like I gotta
move on just stop wasting your time girl
work on you and trust that a better fit
will come
who knows maybe it's Julian
baby
all right next week my mood gets
confronted about some girl he was
chatting with behind Nicole's back who
was the woman I don't know some girl
from China I didn't do something wrong
with this girl or don't I have been
saying prong you definitely crossed some
lines there no no no no no no yes I was
totally inappropriate you know it my
advice to Nicole is to get a divorce
all right
honey
[Music]